i really want to start with
congratulations on the sequel uh it's
real good and i know fans are going to
love it um so i uh that's all i have so
i'll see you guys later
being serious for a second uh you never
know when you're making a movie like
sonic the first one if it's going to be
good what the fan reaction is going to
be so for both of you when did you
realize oh people really like this one
i mean i feel like when well for the
first one when images of sonic were
first released and there was you know
reactions weren't so positive and they
were strong and they were strong and
very vocal um i felt like jeff did such
an amazing job of course correcting and
answering the audiences and the fans you
know
concerns and
they showed up for us in a way that was
just like extraordinary and so i was
really surprised and overwhelmed that
they would if they were so receptive
with you know the final result and the
love is just there for the the whole
canon of of sonic and i just felt you
know i felt that love and it was
definitely um yeah don't take it for
granted
at all
the the sequel is loaded it's bigger and
better and it's just like a roller
coaster ride for both of you what are
you each most excited for fans to see in
the sequel
oh my gosh i think there's so much first
of all the three characters you know
sonic tails knuckles you get to see this
layered interaction you get to see
you know you think it's the end of
sonic's journey but
like we're just scratching the surface
of what sonic is and what he's
discovering about himself um
there's just so much action there's so
much fun when i watched it i had a smile
i think the whole time especially when i
first saw the sega
oh my god it felt so cool so i i think
there's just too many things to pick
just one yeah
i'm definitely excited for them to see
us as action heroes frank that's my
selfish thing i think um
the first film you know i was tied up in
peeing myself for the
large part of my time on screen so i'm
so excited to be free from the chair and
running around with this one who's just
been a joy to work with so
uh yeah to get some feminist
representation we're not being saved
we're the ones doing the saving i think
that's pretty cool and natasha kills it
oh 100
also when where when i saw it not only
was i laughing but like the entire
audience was laughing at some of the
things that you guys will put through
doing you know what i mean that's
awesome exactly
so something else is that uh uh i like
learning about the behind the scenes of
the making of a movie things you might
not normally know so um what do you
think uh fans would be surprised to
learn about the actual making of a sonic
movie uh it felt like an alternate
universe because we're in hawaii and
it's hot but then we're all so cold
you know there's this big snow machine
yeah there's this big scene and your
feet are literally like thawing and
it's just a hot mess but you're like
okay we're here um and then also i think
talking to a tennis ball you know has
been interesting
but you know we had a great uh person
actor who was scott who was doing improv
and really making us feel the characters
um although we didn't really see them so
it made us all feel like we were in this
crazy universe together there's so much
the audience uh just doesn't know i mean
from multiple takes of every scene to
get all the angles and schlepping around
a wedding dress all over the resort and
having you know
uh wardrobe you know carrying around
fans and putting ice packs in fun places
uh i just think that like but it's a
labor of love and i think that that's
the beauty of being able to work on
something that you're really proud of
with people who you really respect and
we were so excited to all be there yes
yeah
uh it totally shows congrats on being
part of a cool sequel and i wish you
guys nothing but the best thank you
you